[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sei que eu não fiz nada para receber
tantos aplausos assim esse aplauso é
fator esse aplauso que vem da platéia
pra gente é fundamental sem definição
para quem vive disso aqui o calor que
vem daí o que pode proporcionar dentro
de nós
o time está presente à platéia tão
calorosa e eu suei da um suor né
determinei a apresentação a minha
primeira filha falou nossa você sua eu
falei também vocês eu boto como eu já
disse a vocês e sua luta faleceu muito
bom como eu disse eu sou ator
mas quando alguém na rua me pergunta que
eu faço na vida respondeu pra ser
sincero eu sou palhaço eu sou palhaço
para ser sincero bom e aí o pessoal
bom aí eu fiquei pensando como tá legal
eu tenho uma boa nova para falar sobre
palhaço porque numa em 7 de todo mundo o
palhaço hoje vem do circuito apresenta
no circo na celebração de fé é a figura
parecida com a do buzu do ronald
mcdonald
mas esse palhaço nenhuma invenção
americana já no início do século 20 para
trazer o público infantil para o circo a
figura do palhaço nunca foi infantil
o palhaço é um arquétipo muito mais
ancestral e se perde nas origens quando
eu falei então de palhaço vou pedir pra
vocês usarem na imagem da de vocês a
figura do chapolin a figura mais
especificamente do carlitos
vejam bem o que é o carlitos pobre
vagabundo perdeu a casa perdeu a família
perdeu tudo né é aquela figura do
vagabundo
o que o shopping bem dizia que o palhaço
não é a alegria da criançada que o
palhaço é o perdedor
sim porque essa é a coisa mais certa da
vida
vejam bem que curioso seria cômico se
não fosse trágico
se tudo der certo nós vamos perder
nossos países está errada que morra
dirigente não quer provocar essa
tristeza mesmo de bom toque de bola onde
nós ea gente não fala neste assunto e há
uma verdade concreta
se tudo der certo a gente vê o colágeno
acabar eu sei que tem gente está
percebendo da pele derreter
fui lugar ck engraçado que a pele cair
sobretudo músculo músicas sobre o outro
no final todo mundo tem cara de godot
se tudo der certo deu pra perceber se
tudo der certo a levantar no banheiro
vai chegar a tempo
nessa hora não se preocupe que eles
botaram uma fralda geriátrica e isso é
verdade mas a gente nunca quer falar
disso
e aí eu falei 'bom se essa é a arte a
arte é a perda
veja bem o palhaço aquele que perdeu
para você ter uma idéia da vida parece é
vermelho porque se ele perdeu a casa e
dorme no relento dorme ao relento e
madrugada ele passa frio
se ele passar por ele então vim pra
esquentar estão vindo a secretária fica
mais ou menos assim com essa moça mais
fraco
ele começa a lembrar da saudade que ele
tinha e começa a chorar eo nariz fica
vermelho a roupa dele larga demais o
curta demais a respeito de marcos que
não pertenciam a ele
então o palhaço simboliza exatamente
isso
aquele que perdeu a dignidade do ser
humano de verdade não se conhece pela
rua inclusive peço desculpas a meus traz
uma xícara de bom combinar com o cenário
bom um palhaço ou o ser humano de
verdade a gente não conhece pelo tênis
pela roupa pelo carro pelo número do
iphone ser humano de verdade você
conhece depois de uma enchente depois do
incêndio
depois da perda de um ente querido
depois de uma separação amorosa depois
de uma demissão depois de uma falência
aquilo que sobra é você
você não é tua roupa você analisa você é
aquilo que sobra quando você perde
alguém muito importante pra você que
você não sabe como você começa outro dia
nem se você deverá se você tiver um
pouco de sentimento agora o nome de
sentimento de amor incondicional
é quando sobra só você
porém cria se uma grande confusão à
então a arte do palhaço ea parte do
perdedor
qual é a graça disse a seu pedido não
porque o shopping quando compôs o cargo
sem ter uma única preocupação de que no
olhar do vagabundo nunca transmite seu
público raiva mágoa ressentimento culpa
e nem culpar ninguém pela condição a que
ele se encontra
ou seja a grande mensagem que dá pro
mundo é que o palhaço é aquele que
aceita porque há certas coisas nessa
vida que nós nunca vamos entender mas a
gente tem que aceitar como a morte
aliás vale para qualquer tipo de perda
essa aceitação faz com que então arte do
palhaço não seja necessariamente ato de
quem cai mas sim a arte de quem se
levanta depois da queda porque somente
quando você aceitar a perda somente
quando você aceita que perdeu é que
talvez você consiga se conectar com
aquelas tais forças misteriosas que
fazemos e se levantar
então uma pessoa comum tropeça e levanta
com vergonha e um palhaço pro peça cai e
levanta com a dignidade de um mestre
sala porque ôôô um grande exercício de
era isso bom eu poderia passar aqui o
meu tempo tomar o resto meu tempo meu
deus do céu
meu tempo falando o que eu sou
inadequado porque a minha descoberta
então ver o caminho de autoconhecimento
foi
o que eu não sou é porque a gente sabe o
que a gente não é a gente sabe que não é
tão bonito
a gente sabe que não é tão alta que sabe
que é tão rico ele sabe que não é tão
inteligente ele sabe que não é tão
perfeito assim mas não pode contar a
ninguém porque não pode ser que pode ser
que não te amo em pode ser que não
gostem de você e aí a grande conclusão
que bruna que a palhaçaria me deu é ser
quem você realmente é ou ser aquilo que
querem que você seja todo meu
aprendizado foi tentando entender quem
eu não era porque eu quero que queria
que eu fosse etapa está claro desde que
a gente nasce quero que você seja um
sucesso financeiro social e sexual tinha
grandes chances não me dar bem nesse
pessoal sobre dois últimos quesitos bom
ficarem isso quem aqui não for branco
hétero homem tem grandes chances na
periferia da tolerância de caber
pertenceu não pertencer ser amado não
ser amado cabelo não caber isso nos dá
nos confere uma enorme sensação de
inadequação e é justamente essa sensação
de inadequação que é a arte do palhaço
de como você se adéqua a este mundo de
vencedores sendo você é um perdedor
então eu quero tocar traduzir isso para
dizer que foi a arte a tecnologia em que
eu me apoiei para a mulher jornada de
autoconhecimento arte como tecnologia
humana eu tinha um de tecnologia humana
assim as psicologias as filosofias
orientais e ocidentais e as práticas
contemplativas me todas porque todas
elas acessam o ser humano com ele mesmo
porém a arte é a única que te impede a
expressar-se a se expressar e você se
expressa pegando coisas que estão no
invisível coisas que estão no
inconsciente onde mora músicas dela ser
feita onde mora a poesia deve ser feita
esse cara vai lá em algum momento pega
isso traz para ele ainda que de maneira
confusa que não esteja muito a luz da
consciência e transmitir devolve-se em
forma de poema tira volta e isso em
forma de canção hora
equivocado sabe ou não é um processo
terapêutico a ser considerado e que
tecnologia é essa
no caso da arte são as remoções para
vocês terem uma idéia é dar mais ou
menos me vejo assim como se fosse um
primata hominídeo com vários softwares
avançados que são as emoções que eu não
sei usar muito bem nenhum deles nós
somos esse macaco que não sabemos usar
muito bem as nossas emoções que eu quero
dizer com isso vou pegar duas emoções
que é comum atores e primitiva tristeza
raiva a raiva por exemplo indica que tem
algo um obstáculo no seu caminho que
precisa ser resolvido
se você não sabe disso tem raiva do
mundo tem raiva do teu filho te rápido
que o patrão tem raiva do mundo quer ver
todo mundo até mesmo se você perceber
que essa tua raiva é porque está fazendo
um trabalho que você não ama você tem
que remover esse obstáculo e não
transferir isso tudo com renda para a
família e para os meus amigos
isso é porque por que você não controla
a emoção da raiva
se você tiver triste atriz está dizendo
para você ei você precisa se conectar
nesse momento você se conectar com você
ou com o outro se você não fizer isso
você sentar no quarto você vai deprimir
porque você não conhece essa emoção
então pra mim tecnologia humana avançada
no grande reaprendendo a aprender dessa
questão é reaprender ou aprender a lidar
e conhecer essas emoções porque de todas
elas ainda têm uma mais potente e aqui
mas nos leva para o céu e aqui mas me
leva pro inferno que é o próprio amor
quem aqui já se estrepou no lugar do
amor levante o braço após a pergunta
agora faz da vida no amor na infância
namorada decência porque a gente fala se
do amor também não amor a rejeição o
abandono o não reconhecimento mesmo amor
excessivo dos pais traz problema então o
amor é mais uma tecnologia que a gente
não está acostumado a lidar com ela o
que é tecnologia de verdade é um
fenômeno algorítmico em que você por
input output reproduz numa ação é real
ou humana por exemplo acontecendo comigo
nessa tecnologia e ele falou em cinco
sacos de pão evita odores apoia com
junte o queijo ele falou me dá um
comando para fazer um sanduíche eu falei
abre o saco ele ficou assim porque a
máquina não sabia que abrirem essa eu
tenho que dar um comando do tipo é meu
braço direito e ângulo de 90 graus hoje
polegar direito com indicador direito em
forma de pinça conduz até a ponta do
sapo foi pega o arame giro quantas vezes
for necessário enfim até pegar até fazer
um sanduíche no mundo do vencedor é o
algoritmo que impera
se tudo der certo para o vencedor o
algoritmo o seguinte se tudo der certo
será o maternal do maternal se tudo der
certo você vai passar o ensino básico
ensino básico 37 prometendo do ensino
médio vai ser muito legal fundamental
vai ser muito legal chegar no
fundamental também e dizem que vai ser
muito mais legal quando você chega no
ensino médio a semana ensino médio lá
acreditando que você vai ser incrível né
ai vai ser uma faculdade que vai ser
legal que vai da faculdade lá aconchego
da família provavelmente após retomada
da sua esposa na faculdade e se um der
certo se tudo der certo você vai se
informar se vai ter um emprego legal se
vai voltar pra família você vai casar
com a mulher da faculdade ou não você
vai ter filho e no final lá na frente da
vida
talvez você perceba de dizer ter sido
músico
talvez você perceba que você é gay
talvez você perceba que você não está no
lugar que você deveria aquela sensação
de inadequação surge mesmo diante dos
sinais na vitória e agora porque quando
aparece diante da derrota é mori
mas quando você aparece quando o cara tá
conta com o dinheiro na conta tudo certo
fica mais difícil nesse momento o que
estabelece um sistema educativo você não
é um algoritmo são duas emoções que
estão sendo desagradáveis naquele
momento indicando que talvez você
necessite de mudanças porque as emoções
não são algodão algorithm exatas eu não
conheço nenhum computador que tenha se
apaixonado por uma computador pode ser
que não demora muito tempo mas isso
ainda não foi feito então falando da
honda da arte como tecnologia humana
quero acreditar que este
gurila hoje rádio de pilha com um
processador do iphone 7 começa a
funcionar em que medida na medida em que
eu conheço as minhas emoções e vou em
busca delas principalmente as que não
comiam imperfeição combina adequação com
aquilo que eu já aceito que eu não serei
jamais
aquilo me coloca no lugar de relaxamento
na banda na hora de buscar tem osso
nesse momento o ser humano acho que ele
entra no viés da sua evolução do seu da
sua principal missão que é seguir
evoluindo evoluindo sem parar
nesse momento quando você diz dominar as
emoções passaremos a ser uma plataforma
de transformação tecnologia de
transformação de autotransformação e de
transformação do outro porque você e
transforma o outro a partir da sua
própria e aí se resolve aquele velho
problema daquela grande dicotomia da
arte do palhaço que é ser quem você
realmente é ou será que querem que você
seja por isso que parece propensa a que
ele sempre vai ter lugar o objetivo do
sonho
ele sempre vai voando por lugar do
objetivo então ele nunca olha pra onde
anda
a solução então é ao invés de passarmos
a vida gastando nossa energia para
tentarmos ser mais do que a gente é ou
tentando não ser menos daquilo que você
sabe que pode ser que você pegar essa
energia somente para pensar e tentar
entender qual é o seu real tamanho
porque quando você percebe qual é o teu
real tamanho você passa a caber em
qualquer lugar
meu nome é marcio libar e como arte do
palhaço é a arte da verdade eu vou
terminar esse tal que com a verdade do
meu nome e meu nome verdadeiro não é
marcio libar chegaram chocados né meu
nome verdadeiro é márcio lima barbosa
lima por parte de mãe e barbosa pai do
amigo do meu pai
o cairo
[Música]
[Aplausos]